black culture celebrated these three
young women are on a kind of pilgrimage
to London's Notting Hill Carnival a
festival of all things afro-caribbean
it's a party
but its history is more sober when you
come here you need to understand what
the roots are and how important it be
you know those roots are in the 1950s
when there was widespread violence
against black families and now that
sense of protest has a new name black
lives matter I think I think it's been
actually a lot of different people
together lots of different ethnicities I
think as well I mean the the core root
of it is the progression of black people
and recognizing our right
autonomy I also think that lots of
people coming together and joining the
movement and recognizing how much how
much bad fare we've had I think
being black is focusable and it's more
than just a color it's filled into the
target and it is when people see you
they see blackness and blackness has all
these negative connotations that white
people have authority from the baton is
there for us to but I'm praying or
telling people that our lives do matter
like black people
our lives are very important and it's
not below anyone elses not below like
the lives of white people so I think
we've kind of all kind of goes away with
black people come together we're
embracing each other
blacklivesmatter has grown up as a
movement in the u.s. provoked by the
deaths of unarmed African Americans at
the hands of the police
that is it now a British movement - it's
a busy Sunday evening in Brixton and
this part of London is leaving with
trendy types just enjoying the
atmosphere but historically Brixton is
home to Britain's black community just a
few moments away from here there's a
very real sense of the struggles back
community is still facing Marcy reg has
come to Brixton with other families
affected by deaths following police
contact her brother Sean died in 2008
today is the 8th anniversary of his
death 21st of August 2008 when Sean's
mental health deteriorated his care team
called the police they refused to come
until a member of the public dialed 999
Shaun was then put in a police van he
was kept in the back of a van for 11
minutes and then he appears on camera
clearly unwell and on the floor this
footage of Shaun at Brixton police
station was part of the evidence at his
inquest a jury found that the police
scene he is suggesting he could be
faking unconsciousness contributed to
his death claimed that he just wanted to
sleep they stand Shaun up and Shaun is
clearly Innes and in a collapsed state
and and he died shortly after he died on
a co floor at the feet of police
officers you just
we were not able to hug Shawn or kiss
Shawn and I'm fact I've never seen
Shawn's body because he was covered from
the chin down I've heard this from many
other families and they were he was
behind the locked glass which was
horrific secondly he's trying to
convince the IPCC to interview the
police officers as to find out what
happened and to cease to seize the
evidence and it's extraordinary that's
that's not automatically dying Theresa
May last year announced a review in two
deaths in custody which is due to report
in the coming weeks police custody is
the place where a number of dynamics
meet it is the place where dangerous and
difficult criminals are rightly locked
up where officers and staff regularly
face violent threatening and abusive
behavior and where the police use some
of their most sensitive and coercive
powers but it is also a place where all
too often vulnerable people often those
with mental health problems are taken
because there is no other place to go
vulnerable people like Sean Rigg who
died not far from here in Brixton Police
Station big dangerous but really they're
not criminals they are somebody that are
extremely unwell and vulnerable and with
we don't have superhuman strength black
people are not madder than anybody else
but we seem to be treated differently
are they scared of us why is that for
Marcia and thousands of others this has
been a summer of protests my sons are
stopped and searched
they've been stopped and searched since
they were 10 years old my children get
Rachel
looks and stares because of the dad's
dark and I've got two films with blonde
hair and they automatically are judging
in what's going on their blood the
summers protests were already well
underway when news broke of another
death this time it was Mo's a Muhammad
just 18 years old police say they were
called to reports of a man acting
erratically at a Liverpool shopping
center footage shows him surrounded by
police and security guards he would soon
be dead
hay was already so much anger at black
deaths following police contact and then
the here in Liverpool with a Muhammad
died the grief is really raw I've come
to the opening of the inquest to speak
to his family as they begin their search
for answers they already have concerns
about how the IPCC's investigation is
progressing for some at least maybe get
one answer but it's like they're sitting
back and taking the time it's not
acceptable than 18 you know especially
being our family and our loved one
snatched away off the streets and no
justice and nothing's done about it and
people want i pc that want to react as
fast as they acted on the day these 18
years of age of his life spoon taking
away he's never gonna see a day he's
never gonna get a chance to advocate
he's never going to see the child again
they've now joined the growing number of
families at the heart of the black lives
matter movement
Kingsley Burrell died after calling the
police
fearing he was being targeted by violent
youths he was detained under the Mental
Health Act for four days an inquest
found prolonged restraint and a failure
to provide medical care contributed to
his death Kings was vulnerable and when
they arrived they came with battens they
came with Tasers they came would dogs
part of finding his excessive force used
for a prolonged period of time and he
had a restraint so he had hand
restraints leg restraints no
that he also had the blanket covering
that was over his head as well
any day now Khadija is expecting a
decision from prosecutors as to whether
any officers will stand trial but
impatience with the CPS in Birmingham is
mounting
Kingsley's death has become yet another
central to the black lives matters
grievances but do the numbers stack up
our black people disproportionately
dying following contact with the police
well I actually the figures show at the
moment it is in proportion to the people
who are being arrested and actually
there's been a fall in the number of
issues and incidents over the last year
but there's always more to do we need to
make sure any injury any death is a
tragedy and we need to make sure we do
everything we can to ensure that doesn't
happen the actual numbers of people
dying in police custody remain
relatively small black people have been
disproportionately represented over time
but in recent years the numbers have
fallen it's the nature not just the
number of those deaths that most
concerns campaigners where there's a
real issue is about the disproportionate
number of black people who died
following the use of force they are the
most contentious deaths they've raised
serious public and political disquiet
and they raise concerns about racial
profiling we had a recent inquest into
the death of Kingsley Burrell in
Birmingham where the language used was
so familiar oh you know Kingsley being
the strongest man that they'd ever come
across and you see the kind of racial
profiling and perceptions and that I
think has informed the way in which
those officers have responded which is
the idea of black men being inherently
you know big back and dangerous those
kind of stereotypes which I do think
seep into the police consciousness and
they inform the way the individuals are
then treated there have been many
investigations but so far not a single
conviction of a police officer for a
death in custody now Britain's black
lives matter movement has seen ordinary
people of all races take to the streets
in protest
but for black people it's more than that
and nowhere is that more clear than at
London's carnivals celebration of black
culture
and it's been many of the people who
shed its cultural heritage but embrace
the fat legs not through
passion and identity the new generation
whole range prejudice discrimination
faith-filled I think is leading to black
pride pluck empowerment and black
freedom but liberation I think now it's
something we're coming out of the box
and were telling people that we're not
were no longer accepting written from
people no longer being silent about it
and I think we're coming to a point
where black people are not afraid to
vocalize black lives matter has taken on
its own British identity along with the
uniquely British sense of grievance but
it's about optimism - and the belief
that this time protests will lead to
change